let's bring in Chris CLM now former
border patrol chief for the Yuma Arizona
sector he started his career in El Paso
uh thank you very much for joining us
first weigh in please as we continue to
see these live pictures of very clearly
migrants continuing to overwhelm our
Southern border uh both in Texas and
Arizona
sir yeah thank you for having me on
thank you for continuing this coverage
this is like a a horror version of
Groundhog Day the movie this has been
going on for the last several years on
this Administration um I was just in
lukeville last week witnessed it
firsthand you know a thousand people on
the ground mainly uh adult males some
family uh uh groups there but you're
seeing this just like in Griff's report
from El Paso or excuse me Eagle Pass all
the way to uh to lukeville Arizona this
has been going on day in and day out for
the last several years and uh you know
I'm glad that there are Governors and
some independent Mayors and people
standing up saying enough is enough we
have got to send a clear message to
Washington that you know what you messed
up the policy that you put in place are
not working and Americans and the
migrants are are paying the price well
uh outnumbered and out resourced this is
uh the Arizona governor Katie Hobbs
calling on federal reimbursement
listen Arizona can't do this alone nor
should we have to we're asking the
federal government to reimburse us for
the cost uh to arizonans for far ton
Arizona has borne the brunt of federal
in action on our Southern border and I'm
tired of it this is bip part an outrage
over this happening does that give you
some sort of Hope um that they'll be
able to push the White House on this
issue well I that's what we have to to
bank on is that uh some of the members
of the president's own party are very
frustrated you know I'm glad that she
went down there the Border U she's been
dealing with this and and been aware of
this and she took office uh that
reimbursement is really to pay you know
the uh the state and and government and
local agencies that have been you know
dealing with the release and the
shelters and Arizona taxpayers like
myself shouldn't have to bear the brunt
of a of a federal problem and you know
what's so amazing about this is if a
state was to take action to try to take
you know uh decisive enforcement actions
this same Administration would come
after them and that's where this
hypocracy coming out of Washington DC
when it comes down to this border is is
beyond uh you know frustrating and you
know again this this was this was fixed
we were at the best place and the most
secure border that I had been working
with
at that point 25 years and and it all
got changed I think nothing more than
political Spite and and just frustration
with the previous administration we were
we were getting there and uh and and
they really wasted some opportunities
here and Chris I I keep highlighting
these live images because I mean we're
showing them this is our Fox Flight Team
otherwise you wouldn't be seeing these
images I mean this is constant this flow
is constant um we were this time
yesterday covering the exact same story
and a steady flow of migrants coming
over
having to be processed by these border
patrol agents you mentioned frustration
there's frustration all over the country
you just heard from the governor of
Arizona a Democrat here's the New York
city mayor Adams expressing frustration
about the Border um at there was this
meeting in DC just last week here's the
mayor I did not see the level of urgency
I'm just not seeing uh the you know the
White House and their colleagues up
there understanding that we need a
decompression strategy
should not be carrying the burden of a
national crisis and when I left DC I did
not walk out and say uh that you know
the calvary is coming all right so he's
acknowledging this is a national crisis
uh he's dealing with this right here in
New York City he said I'm just not
seeing the White House and their
colleagues up there understanding that
we need a strategy here's the Border
crisis by the Numbers Chris this is what
we're looking at 5,000 migrants released
every day into the country
uh we had a record 12,000 migrants that
were encountered this was just last week
that is the highest number ever um do
you see any signs of this
abating well no and you know let me just
say uh something about mayor Adams he
sent his team down the Border last year
I met with his team and we explained
this that this is what was happening
this is what was coming to a city near
them and uh you know I'm glad they're
finally getting very frustrated and
vocal but look this is what those
numbers that you're showing is something
that we live for the last few years what
I lived as Chief and what they're living
right now it it I don't see any
abatement and and what's happening is
what the what the administration is
putting forth as far as their budget is
to you know expedite and efficiently
process these migrants once they're in
our custody to get them released you
know that is that is again a poll factor
that uh other guests and other people
have talked about if there is not a
consequence if there's no you know uh
reason to stop them they're going to
keep coming and if we're just going to
put technology olog to efficiently
process them that's a continuous pull
factor we've got to shut it down we need
to get the the suborder secure we need
to get things in place and then and then
at that point can we address what that
that lawful pathway should be okay
chrisc thank you very much for joining
us as we continue to watch this uh at
our Southern border uh we will see what
happens next as there are B bipartisan
calls now uh to do something thank you
sir I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian kilme and
I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis